I have a motto higher fast fire faster
promote fastest and yet I'll be honest
here and very vulnerable I struggle to
play that course because for me
personally the emotion of hurting
someone trumps the financial impact of
it and where I was able to mature into
later in my life was understanding the
ramifications it was having on everyone
else it wasn't about me I really do
think a lot of people struggle with the
emotional baggage of hurting someone
Vayner Nation how are you new episode of
the podcast interviewing
some of the most interesting people in
the world I'm excited to do an original
show I know we take a lot of clippings
for my Keynotes and my runarounds uh I'm
in extra good mood because drock is
filming today and some old good feelings
I'm also extremely excited because we
have a a tremendous guest today that I
think a lot of you have been affected by
and uh and I always think that's super
cool when there's uh someone who's uh
invented or impacted us in a big way and
so I'm going to let Yuri uh uh introduce
himself uh and tell you who he is and
then we're gonna get into a series of
questions and uh touch on a bunch of
subjects here so Yuri how are you my
friend thank you I'm awesome
um so as you said my name is uhuri
Levine I'm co-founder of Waze which I
assume many people use around the globe
actually about a billion you know so if
movie which is another billion users
around the globe in author of the book
fall in love with the problem not the
solution
yes I see you you know for people that
are listening it is uh wearing a t-shirt
right now fall in love with the problem
not the solution you've been a
co-founder in two companies that have a
billion people using it which is just
outrageous
um
would you argue that your passion for
the statement that you just made a is
the reason you've been able to
accomplish being involved in those kind
of products because obviously you're
solving a major problem to get that
level of usage and then number two if
you may when do you think you started
falling in love with the problem not the
solution was that something God given
was that something you were around as a
child
who influenced you how did you stumble
on that concept
so at the end of the day I found myself
attracted to problems in a way that that
I get frustrated and I ask myself is
that so is that the only way that can be
done and I try to figure out a solution
but over the years what I've learned is
that way before you can figure out a
solution what you really want to do is
make sure that this problem is actually
applying to a lot of people right so
think of a problem a big problem
something that's worth solving and then
ask yourself so who has this problem now
if you happen to be the only person on
the planet with this problem then I
would say you know what go to a shrink
it's way cheaper
than building but if a lot of people
have this problem what you want to do
next is actually go and speak with those
people and understand their perception
of the problem if they're going to Echo
back the problem to you then this is
actually a very powerful State a
starting point because what will happen
is that number one you will fall in love
with the problem number two you feel
like they are sending you on a mission
to actually address that and when you
are in love with the problem the problem
is going to serve as the north star of
your journey which is going to make your
journey faster and easier because there
will be less deviation of that and that
one is that the story that you're gonna
tell way more compelling just imagine
that we will be here in 2007 and I will
tell you I'm going to build an AI
crowdsource based navigation system and
you're going to say yeah really
interesting but you don't care if I will
tell you I'm going to help you to avoid
traffic jams and
this is the power of a problem approach
or falling in love with the problem that
your story is way more compelling the
likelihood of being successful is way
more and at the end of the day what we
really want as entrepreneurs is to
create value if you solve a problem you
create value
you know when tell actually let's take
us all the way back because I have a
funny feeling we have some similarities
in our uh and our origin stories where
were you born
I was born in Tel Aviv and I was born
and raised here in Israel
um and uh um and ended up to be uh you
know as a teenager and a travel maker
pretty smart one but a troublemaker and
this turns out to be one of the things
that you don't take anything for granted
right and so people would think of you
as a pick or or someone that is asking
annoying and challenging questions
um and um and I grew up in the house
that was encouraged me to discover right
so so if I would come to my dad with a
crazy idea he would say uh
why don't you give it a try right he
would know that it's not going to work
but he would say encourage me to try and
and there was no judgment if if it
didn't work out because that was the
expectation but the discovery that you
fail and get up and nothing happened is
actually very powerful because it's
gonna take you throughout your entire
life and basically saying you know what
you to that point do you feel that micro
failures in your youth became
foundational to your professional
success absolutely absolutely and for a
second I would say we as parents
the most important thing that we would
like to teach our kids is to fail the
reason would you would you agree with me
that we've gone completely the other way
in the last 25 years absolutely it looks
like it right so so I you know I'm
trying to encourage my kids to fail and
to expand their boundary and get out of
their comfort zone and discover what is
it that is going to make them happy
right then because at the end of the day
you don't know right I don't know what's
going to make my kids happy no one knows
they don't need to find out right and
the best way to find out is actually go
to different places and try to find out
but and so this turns out to be
um very very important and I think that
as a society we miss that we have huge
fear of failure that is being
you know encourage the fear of failure
is being encouraged right just imagine
what's going to happen if you if you're
gonna fail test right if you're gonna
bring the f
I mean I I could not agree with you more
all my D's and F's in school
are foundational to my happiness my lack
of anxiety and my professional success
period
yeah not all of them but most of them
yeah yeah I mean I got A's and Jim
because I like sports but other than
that it looks pretty ugly right there
you're when did you when did you think
you had did you you know we grew up in a
generation you how old are you my friend
I'm 58. you look great so I'm 47 you and
I grew up in a generation where
entrepreneurship wasn't almost even a
word it was you know it wasn't the
culture that we have today did you sense
that you had that Spirit did you have a
knowledge of what you could do did you
grow up in an entrepreneurial household
were your folks entrepreneurs or was it
something you discovered later in life
so uh my dad was an entrepreneur you
know he built factories you know this is
the partnership of the previous century
and my mom was a teacher and a professor
at the University and I ended up to be a
little bit of both right so I'm not one
in but also a teacher on the other hand
and this is by the way why I wrote this
book I feel equally rewarded when I
built stuff myself or I guide someone to
build it and the result is that I have
about 10 different startups that I'm
mentoring the CEO and coaching them and
and helping them to become more
successful and the book is all about
that right is sharing my know-how that
will help other people to become more
successful
what was the most challenging thing in
writing the book
starting
how long did you debate it before you
started it so so I think that the
foundations of the book was uh was laid
back in 2016 when I actually did uh an
MBA uh seminar for building startups and
I ended up with pretty much most of the
content and then I told myself wait a
minute I actually have your accountant
for writing a book
um and it was later until my mom told me
that I should be writing a book which
was the second trigger for that yeah
with uh kovid that um you know I found
myself stuck at home before that I was
traveling quite a lot and going to you
know multiple conferences and meeting a
lot of people and then I was ended up to
be stuck at home and I realized that now
I have the time in with the help of uh
Diva real that was um really the project
managerian the co-editor and the the you
know the partner of writing this book
um we spent about a year writing it and
this is a discovery process at the
beginning Until you realize okay this is
how it's going to work right and um and
then you end up with uh writing the book
and realizing that um you just move one
phase in the journey now you need to
promote the book and make sure that
actually a lot of people are reading the
book because otherwise the impact is
going to be minimal and I want a bigger
impact I want at the end of the day
my purpose my mission is to create value
so the more people reading the book The
more value that they create and I feel
you know rewarded
and and that's what makes you allocate
the work of doing podcasts like this
because you want as much exposure as
possible exactly
good for you talk to me about the
origins of Waze I just think that so
many people here I'm like I gen I
actually don't know it so I'm like
excited my darn self to hear what's
about to come out of your mouth how did
this company that really you know you
talk about forget about you know I love
how you said storytelling because that
shows the marketer in you you know AI
you know mapping fine I'm gonna save you
time you know I'm Gonna Save You to
avoid traffic even better story and then
you've got Maniacs like me hey I'll save
you four minutes in a day I'll pay
anything for those four minutes which is
why I was obsessed with ways the second
it came out
um how in the world did that company
start
so so the magic of ways is that way is
crowdsource everything right there is no
data coming from anyone else except the
drivers so we crowdsource all the
drivers together and we you know based
on where you are and how fast you're
done you're going we know exactly where
traffic jams are if you report that
there is a speed cam which is equally
important as be as um as uh I'm dry as
finding out or avoiding traffic jams
um it's uh it's reported by other
drivers in the map itself is being
generated by the drivers as they drive
right if you drive somewhere then I know
that it's drivable
um the idea came to my mind back in 2006
when we were um as a family we were at a
family gathering up the northern part of
Israelis Israel is a small place it's
about the same size as a Massachusetts
right and um and we were like 10 cars
there and when it was the end of the
weekend we drove home we at the time had
four little kids so it took us longer to
arrange everyone and gather everyone put
them back into the car and everyone
already left and and there were back
then two routes two alternative routes
going from the northern part of Israel
back to Tel Aviv and I um called up all
of the other cars and asked them how is
traffic like on your path and what I
found out is that in one route it's
actually pretty okay and the other one
it was really crowded and I realized
that what I really need is someone ahead
of me on the road to tell me what's
going on
that was an idea that I was trying to
promote
um with different partners and it didn't
work out until 2007 when I met my other
co-founder
um Amira nahoud
and um and we actually share the vision
now what it turns out is that the hood
was already in a process of building a
prototype of um
crowdsourcing the map data which was
mandatory part of that and then we
decided that this is what we're going to
build we're going to build ways and
we're going to help drivers to avoid
traffic jams and we're going to focus on
the drivers on their daily commute
so the use case is very different that
the result is that you know if I would
ask today drivers how often do you use
Waze they will tell me every day right
if I would ask people that are using
Google Maps how often do you use Google
Maps they will tell me when I need it
right in in the need for ways is
actually on the daily commute and we
started the journey in 2007 in the first
version of Waze was running on a PDA
remember yeah a long time ago they were
dinosaurs and then and they Nokia phones
and we they all have iPhones and Android
right this is 15 years that's it
and um we raised at that point at that
point people forget that they're very
young there was that those Gremlins
right those plugins that you put into
the and it was that was really kind of
that the play the pre the iPhone
um they wear the use case was when you
go to a place that you don't know
yeah and we turned that around by
basically saying you know what we're
gonna create we're gonna help you to to
save a few minutes every every day right
and occasionally a lot of minutes right
because if there is an accident or
something like that
as it ended up can I ask you a quick
question I'm sorry to interrupt but this
is how my brain works
why do humans even when Waze is telling
them the right answer
decide I can't wait to hear your take on
this
it is unbelievable watching humans when
the data is so profound
that they still have to go some other
way as if they feel like they know
better
so in most cases they simply don't pay
attention they simply pay attention they
you know they this is the the route that
they're doing people like drock who are
just stubborn and think they know better
what about those people like that
obviously there are always people like
that right then uh and some some
actually told me that they are actually
competing with ways every day
there is a fastest route
um I don't know I would say it's
possible but less likely
um and and so we ended up with uh and
this is really interesting right we
start ways in the tagline of ways was uh
outsmart traffic together right so so
outsmarting is the most important thing
right but as it turns out over the years
people don't necessarily take the
fastest route what they really care
about is the the how long it's going to
take them to get there and the the
certainty versus uncertainty is the
major value that Waze is actually
creating for most people so you know
exactly when you're gonna get there and
that's it and it's not a big deal
um and so we started the journey we
raised Capital 2008 we built the first
version on smartphones we went to the
market at the beginning of 2009 and that
was in Israel and it was actually pretty
good and then we beginning of 2010 we
tried to make it available everywhere
and it was not good of and this is where
the realization that building a startup
is a journey of failures coming from
you know it doesn't work
and and you speak with the drivers they
tell you that doesn't work for them you
build the next version you know that
this is it and it's not so you think it
all over again you speak with the
drivers you understand where the
problems are you build the next version
you know that this is it and it's not
iteration after iteration after
iteration more than a year of iterations
until it's become good enough and so
today when I Define
when I Define building a startup is a
journey then I will Define three
dimensions to this journey the first one
is going to be a roller coaster here
with ups and downs and ups and downs
that and look Phil tell me all the
businesses in the world have ups and
downs every but the frequency of those
when you're building a startup in the
amplitudes are way higher I think that I
heard the best quote from from Ben
horvitz Ben horwich is one of the
founders of adversion Orbitz Venture
Capital firm and before that he used to
be a CEO of a startup and he was asked
whether or not he was sleeping well at
night as a sea officer he said oh yeah I
slept like a baby I walk up every two
hours and cried and that's the roller
coaster chair
the second part of the Dragon it's going
to be a very long one until you figure
out product Market feed and product
Market feed is when you bring value to
your users or to your customers and if
you don't figure out product Market feed
you will die as simple as that yep in
fact you never heard of a company that
did not figure out product Market free
they simply died that's it has never
never happened
um actually on that point because I see
this here I want to get to this because
we're going to run out of time with you
know fall in love with the problem not
the solution these are things that you
touch on we just talked about it how to
figure out product Market fit which is
huge and I think
to be very Frank 90 of people are are
naive about that truth they would like
to see something exist but they've given
they've given no humility or curiosity
to the product Market fit so I love that
you touch on that then you talk about
how to determine your business model and
and lock down your growth plan you also
talk about the key components of
building a successful startup that will
disrupt broken markets which I love
because you've scratched that itch I'm
going to let you jump into which one you
want here but I just want to touch on
this for the people that are listening
if they're considering the book I have
good news for Yuri this was a good use
of your time this audience loves reading
books so you're going to be very happy
with me when you see the data on Amazon
after this podcast there's
um the this one I love the importance of
firing and hiring the right people yes
in that order I have another I'm really
excited to see that deciding when to
sell and how entrepreneurs can prepare
for the eventual exit of the company
that's super interesting because you
guys only ran ways for how long before
you sold to Google
about six years or officially five years
really short period very short period of
time uh and then the importance of
paying it forward and guiding others uh
entrepreneurs in need which I love so
much and I love that you end with that
of the things that I just brought up
which was really a primer for the
audience in case I didn't get to it on
things you can expect from the book I
Still Believe Books are one of the best
rois in the world when I think about the
people that write books and I think
about the effort they put into it and I
think about all that information costing
about 20 bucks I still think it's one of
the great rois that exist of the things
that I just brought up that you touch on
in this book
which one would you like to double click
into and speak on a little bit
so what uh double click into firing and
hiring this is really interesting and we
will double click on more and then you
know if you'll give me the rest of the
evening here in Tel Aviv then we will
spend the rest of the evening here we've
got seven minutes so like you know
that's how it's gonna really play out
we spoke with many entrepreneurs that
their startup failed and ask them why
what happened
in about half say the team was not right
and I kept on asking okay what do you
mean the team was upright and what I
heard the most is you know we had this
guy not good enough and this guy so not
good enough was the main reason another
reason that I heard often is that we had
that communication issues right
something that I actually called the ego
management issues and then ask them the
most interesting question when did you
know
but him is not right
all of them knew within the first month
within the first month they said wait a
minute if you knew within the first
month that the team is not right and you
didn't do anything the problem was not
that the team was not right the problem
was that the CEO did not make our
decision making easy decisions is easy
making hard decisions is hard this is
why most people don't like to make them
in a small organization like a startup
it will go all the way to the top to the
CEO to make those now if the seal
doesn't make those decisions this is
where it's becoming complicated right
yes and the reason is a simple right
startup is a small organization just
imagine that you're in a small
organization 10 20 30 40 people
and there is someone that shouldn't be
there
everyone knows
yes everyone knows and the CEO doesn't
do anything that's where the the nature
it's a Crusher exactly and then what
happened
the top performing people would leave
yep they become demotivating because
they don't want to be in an organization
that is unable to make our decision and
they have a choice
now if you have people that shouldn't be
there and the top performing people are
leaving that's the beginning of the end
for you that's the way that you can
recover
one of the major conclusions of the
chapter firing and hiring is look
if you hire someone you if you're a
hiring manager and you hire someone you
mark your calendar for 30 days down the
road and ask yourself one question
knowing what I know today would I hire
this person
now if the answer is no then fire them
immediately you're doing yourself a
favor the rest of the team of favor the
organizational favor and that particular
person you're doing them a favor because
they're not going to be successful here
you already said that trajectory because
you don't think that you should have
hired them
and the reality is that if you don't act
everyone else knows and they see that
you don't act and this is really really
important in general I can say that for
everything in your life right
knowing what unite today if you're gonna
do if you would do something different
then do something different today
basically tell yourself no no I'm going
into the wrong path then stop and change
right because today is the first day why
do you think most people struggle with
making the tough call
because it's hard because you need to
live with the consequences because what
if I'm wrong
now this is really interesting spoke
with my CEOs in my team that had to
release someone from the management team
right so obviously if this is an
employee somewhere else then they don't
even know about it but the management
team right and ask them when did you
fire this person the answer was always
the same
way too late yeah
yeah I have a I have a motto fire
you know higher fast
or faster promote fastest
and yet I'll be honest here and very
vulnerable I struggle to play that
course because for me personally
the emotion of hurting someone
trumps the financial impact of it and
where I was able to mature into later in
my life was understanding the
ramifications it was having on everyone
else it wasn't about me but I was you
know at the time I was in my early 20s
building my father's business and I and
really even into my late 30s I really
struggled with it and even today my last
book I called 12 and a half
and they talked about these traits that
mattered and I spoke about the half
which mine was Candor and it was a
struggle for me it's why it was only a
half I still needed to get to a full I
really do think a lot of people struggle
with the emotional baggage of hurting
someone
I agree I'm just saying it's actually
the other way around so let me say the
following like if you're gonna hire
someone
you are going to have sleepless nights
100 painful because it's hard because
it's our decision and you afraid that
you're gonna hurt someone and we don't
want to hear that Earth you know someone
that we just hired or someone that is
with us right but the reality is that
you are hurting them when you are not
because they're living in a fake
environment they deserve to be
successful
successfully they're working in a fake
environment you've you've read you've
already killed them but they're a dead
man walking exactly and this is why I'm
saying
when you hire mark your calendar for 30
days down the road and then make the
decision because that decision is going
to be way less painful if you let it
drag for a long period of time right if
you let it drag for a long period of
time then everyone is becoming vested
into that if it's only a month after
that you hire them it's easier for you
and they deserve to be successful
that was the most interesting question
the most interesting answer about this
question is when you ask yourself
would I hire this person and the answer
is yes
this is the time to go and tell this
person that they exceed your expectation
that you are very pleased with the fact
that they have joined the organization
and if you can do any sort of
demonstrating that for example giving
them more equity
that's exactly the time to do that
because this is where you establish the
trust and the Loyalty with someone that
you basically just say that you are very
happy with the hiring yeah I love that
you're in our in our last minute or two
here anything you want to touch on
so you know I'm going back into um
into product Market feed and into
understanding users we tend to think
that we are
the typical user
and we are actually an amazing sample
of one person that's it and if we want
to build something that will be
applicable to billions of peoples to
everyone then we need to understand that
not all the users are the same they are
different users and they have different
types of behaviors and they might be
using the product differently and
capture the value differently and the
only way for us to find out is to
actually watch users and then ask them
why
and so perhaps the most important part
in the Journey of trying to figure out
product Market feed is watching users
and asking them why why you have done it
this way and not this way why you didn't
do this and and so forth so you can
understand and improve your product
I love it
friend I'm uh I really enjoyed our time
together congratulations on your success
I've known of you and your successes
from very very far away we've never had
the chance to interact I I
easily said yes when this crossed my
desk I want to support your book my
intuition is that it's going to be
valuable for a lot of the readers that
are listening to this and I wish you
nothing but happiness and success thank
you same here
cheers
[Music]